welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to begin with major developments on an
overnight job action against one of the
country's big Three automakers for the
first time in more than a decade workers
are staging a nationwide strike against
General Motors Auto Workers leadership
says more than 48 thousand of its
members are part of a work stoppage that
began at midnight the union is demanding
what it calls fair wages affordable
health care and more job security Dean
Reynolds is at GM's Detroit ham track
assembly plant where workers are
protesting this morning even what
prompted this walkout
well the union's contract with GM
expired on Saturday after months of
negotiations and while those talks are
expected to continue later today the
strike effectively shuts down some 50 GM
sites from Texas to Michigan and could
adversely impact operations in Canada
and Mexico Union Auto Workers started
gathering around midnight at this
Detroit General Motors plant and others
like it across the country the strike
comes after GM's 2015 labor deal with
the Union expired Saturday over fault
lines ranging from wages to health care
coverage we stood up for GM when they
needed us you deserve a fair contract
because we have we've helped make this
company what it is almost a decade after
its 2009 bankruptcy General Motors made
8.1 billion dollars last year and its
CEO earned nearly 22 million dollars
according to the company's previous
union contract GM's hourly Auto Workers
make anywhere from roughly forty four to
ninety nine thousand dollars a year now
the Union argues it deserves a bigger
share of the profits it helped create
but GM leadership insists its proposed
contract is competitive we think this
offer is very sound and strong with
investments in job creation the auto
makers suggested deal includes over
seven billion dollars in domestic
investment more than 54
new jobs and a ratification payment of
$8,000 per worker I think there's a lot
of frustration on both sides the union
vice-president Terry did it says GM's
terms represent some progress but not
enough and the stakes are high both
parties will work hard to to reach that
agreement there's thousands of families
depending on that now the walkout is
happening at the same time as a federal
investigation of top union officials
involving allegations of embezzling
stealing and otherwise misusing union
funds for personal benefit GM says it is
deeply concerned by those allegations
but a union official tells us that they
will not hinder contract negotiations
Tony all right Dean thank you very much